i've written out two numbers here and
they both contain four or they each have
four as a digit and i want to think
about what the values of these fours are
and to actually compare them so i
encourage you to pause the video and try
that on and try that out on your own so
let's look at the two fours here
so in 110
413 i have a 4
right over here and what does that
actually represent
well this is the ones place you have
three ones
you have one tens
and the four is in the hundreds place
you have four
hundreds so this four literally
represents four
times one hundred or four hundred
now what about this four
well once again you have what zero ones
you have
five tens
three hundreds
and you have
four
you have four thousands
four thousand so this literally
represents four times one thousand
four times one thousand which is four
thousand
so we can now compare the two the four
in one hundred ten thousand four hundred
thirteen
is one tenth the value of the four in
fifty four thousand three hundred and
fifty
and it makes complete sense
this 4 is one place to the right of this
4. this 4 is in the thousands the
magenta circled 4 is in the hundreds so
every time we move a place value to the
right we're going it represents what the
each each increment
represents one tenth as much assuming we
have the same digit so a four in
thousands is four thousand a four and
hundreds would be one tenth as much a
four in the tens would be one tenth as
much as that so we could write a
sentence
the
write it this way
value
of
the
of the four
in this number
is
1 10
the value
of
the
four
of the four
in
this number and it's a little bit weird
sentence the value of the four and 110
413 is one tenth the value of the four
and fifty four thousand three hundred
and
fifty